Speaker 1: All right, let's get through a
couple other things, including a correction,
I mean, I apologize for something I said on
the.
I think it was Monday show which was wrong,
but I'll get to that.
I want to look at an interview that was done
last night on Fox News.
Donald Trump, I was going say, Donald Trump's
former son, former President Donald Trump's
son, Eric Trump.
Still his son, as far as we know, appeared
on Fox News last night, and he said a lot
of things that don't make any sense.
It was a humiliating interview.
It was another one of these face plants where
why does nobody go up to him and say, You
know, sir, these interviews aren't making
you look particularly good.
I'm sure he thinks this makes him look great,
but let's just jump right into it.
The first clip is based on the results of
Virginia, and the context here is really interesting.
I mentioned at on Monday that win or lose
in Virginia, Donald Trump is going to claim
that he was in the right, and he sort of won
on Virginia in the sense that Trump endorsed
Youngkin.
But Youngkin did not embrace Trump's endorsement.
So I predicted if young loses, Trump will
say it's not really a loss for me because
I endorsed him, but he didn't embrace it.
He didn't accept it.
And if Youngkin wins, Trump will say, This
is part of my great track record on endorsements,
which is not so good, and we'll get to that
in a second.
Eric Trump playing right into this and saying
Virginia was a great night for Trump.
He's not even pretending that it's about anything
else for him
Speaker 4: and what a great night this was
was for us and what a great night it was for,
frankly, Trump.
Speaker 2: But it's interesting because your
dad did endorse Youngkin, your dad's track
record.
It's probably second to nobody when it comes
to.
Speaker 1: Yeah, it's actually not a great
record.
Trump likes to say I'm a hundred and fifty
and two or whatever on endorsements.
You can look this stuff up.
Trump's endorsements are widely documented
in the 2018 midterms.
Trump endorsed 75 candidates, and a little
more than half of them won 42 of the 75 one,
that's 55 percent.
That's not that great, particularly when you
consider that most endorsements are incumbents.
And there's a big bias to success with endorsements
because they're already in office and incumbency
has a huge advantage.
During Trump's presidency overall from 2017
to 21, 2021, Trump endorsed 305 people and
then after leaving, Trump endorsed 49 people.
That's a total of 354 endorsements.
Overall, Trump somewhere between 65 and 75
percent.
And again, there is a bias to success because
you mostly endorse incumbents and incumbents
usually win.
So it's not really that great of a track record,
but I guess maybe no one's fact checking it.
Even Trump over the weekend, said the Jeanine
Pirro.
I think I'm one hundred and forty something
and two or something.
Pirro doesn't say a word about it.
She may not know.
She may not care.
OK, let's continue.
Here we go into the supply chain stuff and
with the supply chain stuff, they're not even
pretending that Christmas is about anything
other than gifting cheap Chinese goods to
people.
It's going to ruin Christmas that Chinese
goods are stuck on ships.
Here's Eric Trump.
Speaker 4: That's right, because he's an exciting
guy.
And you know, most politicians, quite frankly,
are.
And my father finally brought some practicality
and a sense of realism to politics that had
never existed before.
And you compare that to Joe Biden right now
who, well, kids Christmas presents are sitting
on ships outside the Port of L.A. because
they can't get ships into our ports in this
country, and they have all sorts of problems,
right?
Yeah, while that's happening.
Joe Biden's over in Glasgow falling asleep
at climate summit.
Right.
Then he has to tell you everything you need
to know about a politician.
Speaker 1: Now again, that doesn't really
have to do with Joe Biden.
There were supply chain issues under Trump,
and there are supply chain issues now.
Nobody was blaming Trump Transportation Secretary
Elaine Chao last year, but now they're blaming
Pete Buttigieg.
They weren't blaming Trump, but now they're
blaming Biden.
But the bigger story for me is, is, is it
are we are we just admitting Christmas is
actually about cheap Chinese goods brought
over on container ships like, oh, there's
not even a pretense that that's not really
the most important part of Christmas.
I don't celebrate Christmas, I don't know.
But I always thought that at least some people
who celebrate Christmas said it was about
something else that the spirit of Christmas
was not cheap.
Chinese goods stuck on ships, OK?
Continuing the supply chain stuff, Eric Trump
says You can't get heating oil and you can't
get gasoline anymore.
Speaker 4: Every product is getting more and
more expensive.
You can't get PVC at a hardware store because
we're not getting it in this country.
I mean, just the basic problems this country
has heating oil, gasoline, everything.
You can't get
Speaker 1: it.
You can't get everything anymore, guys.
I don't know if he thinks this makes him look
good, but it doesn't.
And then lastly, Eric Trump even channeling
Trump now with the verbal slips, referring
to Lt. Governor as Liu Tentent, which is.
I kind of like Lou Lou Tentent,
Speaker 4: and we just have an unbelievable
night, not just with governor, not just the
lieutenant governor, lieutenant with
Speaker 1: lieutenant governor, I like.
OK, all right, guys.
So that's that Eric Trump completely humiliating
himself.